[Musique]
en remontant la route nationale 2 tout à
fait vers le nord le long de la côte de
Caraïbes on arrive au bout du Prêcheur
son nom vient d'un anciennet aujourd'hui
disparu qui avait la forme paraît-il
d'un prédicateur en chair
c'est la dernière commune au nord-ouest
de la Martinique la route cependant se
poursuit au nord au milieu d'une forêt
tropicale jusqu'à l'anse seront et lance
couleuvre elle s'étend sur près de 3000
hectares et compte officiellement un peu
plus de 2200 habitants
le prêcheur a un riche passé historique
c'est tout d'abord l'une des plus
anciennes paroisses de l'île puisqu'elle
date de ses 144 une stèle en marbre
rappelle la mémoire du gouverneur
Jacques Duparquet qui est mort en 1658
tout près des ruines de la prison au fut
enfermé sa femme Marie Duparquet
une autre plaque en souvenir de
Françoise daubinier qui devient plus
tard Madame de Maintenon la seconde
épouse de Louis XIV
en bordure immédiate de la mer dans la
zone soulevant le climat est sec durant
une bonne partie de l'année aussi les
deux ressources principales sont-elles
la pêche et l'agriculture il y a une
soixantaine de pêcheurs professionnels
inscrits à la mairie
[Musique]
l'agriculture traditionnelle de la canne
a pratiquement disparu au bénéfice de la
banane avant la dernière guerre mais
pour cette dernière aussi son
exploitation ne devient plus rentable et
laisse la place peu à peu aux cultures
maraîchères tomates carottes et avocat
pendant la période de récolte qui dure
six mois du 15 juillet au 15 décembre
environ 6 à 7 tonnes d'avocats sont
exportés par semaine vers la métropole
[Musique]
le tourisme enfin commence à se
développer dans cette région le prêcheur
et le point de départ par le chemin de
Grande Savane pour atteindre le sommet
de la montagne Pelée il y a également
les sources chaudes à visiter on peut
aussi en 6 heures de marche rejoindre
l'autre côté et de l'île Grand Rivière
et les touristes seront émerveillés par
la beauté des paysages
[Musique]